today's topic you don't have to settle
for something
because marriage is all about love
respect and all
of that right i guess that's why i'm so
single then i because i really want that
i really want that love respect and all
the shenanigans like how my mom and dad
got it that's exactly what i want
and i i agree there was one girl before
she said that
she would i whatever she said before i
don't remember but she said that
she'd rather have kids on her own and
raise it with her friends or alone i
don't know
something like that but i would i love
kids so i'd rather have
you do you guys not know how terrible
that is like we talk about how difficult
it is raising kids as a single mom we
talk about how many problems that causes
from a
financial side from crime and all this
stuff and i'm like
why are people so casually talking about
raising kids by themselves when it's
like no but
one of the worst environments when it's
one of the worst environments to
potentially raise a kid
i'm not saying that all the single moms
out there are inherently terrible but
like
why would you go into something
inherently saying you want to raise kids
by yourself
by definition they're going to be
missing out on a bunch of stuff that
they need because you're a single parent
so if you end up in that situation
that's one thing but why would you go
into it saying
i would be fine with being a single
parent why okay
so i'll tell you why so basically um
it's better because the thing is we're
limited like our
there's an age limit when we can have
kids and it's there's a time
when it stops so if it gets to that
point i wouldn't say that
i wouldn't want to settle for an unhappy
marriage
or if i'm just gonna fight with with my
partner all the time in front of the
kids
that's actually even worse
than being a single mom do you think do
you think it's a good idea to
birth kids in extreme poverty
no so then why would you think it's a
good idea to birth kids as a single mom
so are you saying that that's going to
be poverty
if i do that but but being a single
parent per whether it's a man or a woman
right it's not the clown the people are
doing this some people just end up in
that
society is it's not by saying that if
you raise a kid
being a single mother you're going to be
in poverty automatically
but we have to realize and we have to be
conscious about
society and how it's constructed
society is made to be lived
in tooth actually not not that it's
going to be it's made like that but
if you separate all the bills and
everything in that and you don't have to
hassle about it
it is easier that's just a fact that's
just mathematics
it's not a way of if you have bills
and you separate them by two and you
live in the same household and you
you you take the stress and you
separated by two
it's gonna be easier if you're a single
mother and all this single shout out to
all the single parents out there
mom or dad single mom or dad that are
alone in dealing with this [ __ ]
it's hard because you have all the
burden on you and i'm talking about a
single parent
not a parent that is single the
difference there
all right where you there's some people
out there that do separate the bills
and they are single that's not that's
not what i'm talking about you still
splitting the bills and [ __ ] like that
well not all the bills because you have
you know household and everything and
stuff but
still life the way it's done it's easier
if you're in two that's the reason why
that was couples
it's just a survival thing when you
learn about
i don't remember what it was i had this
class in in college but anyways
besides the point but it was that you
you you learn about the history of
mankind and the society of different
societies of
that's what it was that's how caveman
and k-woman
got together because of that because it
was easier it's easier if you're a unit
than if you're alone
well that sounds rather extreme my
friend it's not extreme it's
just like anything we can do i can do
better
but it's it's not good circumstances to
raise a child childhood by every
statistical number
it's terrible so why would you do that
if you're saying you don't think it's a
good thing to raise kids in
absolute poverty which i don't
necessarily agree with but that's what
you said
why would you think it's a good idea to
raise them as single parents when
statistically
it's not a good idea at all by the
numbers
but it's not it's not always not a good
idea if you can actually provide
for that child and if you have a support
system and if you live in
a good society and i know how it is i'm
not saying it's gonna be hard but
worst case scenario i need to have a
child i love kids
okay did you hear what she said you
proved your point by just being selfish
she's like yeah yeah i understand what
you're saying i understand what you're
saying but at the end of the day
i need this but it's more than that
listen i think having a child is
inherently yourself
the desire to want a child that's
selfish inherently
you're bringing someone to this world
that didn't ask to be here i agree
but then there's being selfish and then
there's also being irresponsible
okay i didn't make up the numbers in
regards to single motherhood that's not
me
i didn't make a no the numbers up to a
single parent that's not me
right the numbers out there you can look
them up yourself if you want to see the
negative impacts on
mental health poverty uh education uh
crime all these things these are well
documented it's not my opinion most
sociologists agree on this principle so
when this person says
i wouldn't raise a kid in abject poverty
which i would argue is probably a worse
than race but i would raise a kid in
in l it is still not on the environment
because
i really want a child and they see
nothing wrong with it it blows my mind
and and they never speak about what are
the effects on a child
for not having their father they never
speak about that
they never speak and you hear it too she
said i had both my parents and i love
the love that they have and if i can't
have that then i'll just raise my kids
she doesn't even understand what
children from single-parent households
go through
she hasn't even done that research to
understand because she's got both her
parents and her life so there's a
certain
there's a certain irresponsibility to it
that i think is kind of gross and
negligent
and that really struck out but i she
didn't have somebody
she said but i need a child so no
are you saying that it's some kind of
some kind of privilege when both of your
parents
are still married and you were raised by
them is that what you said
so her privilege is not enabling her to
see
how being raised by a single mother or
father can be hard
you know what it's like this is like uh
this is like somebody who came from a
rich family like
i raised my kid in poverty they're going
to be left
i mean i have my parents resources but
my kid doesn't need them
okay [ __ ] look at my face
bro look at my face i am cringing so
hard at this
i'm gonna be honest with you i really
didn't know people said people said
stuff like this
i did because it's just because of her
settings it's really just because of
who we're surrounded with i was not
surprised about this [ __ ] because
the friends of my friends talk like that
sometimes
i've been i've i became acquainted with
it
i became used to it you understand what
i'm saying
i'm used to that to that people talking
like that okay uh there's a couple of
things that i got to say that's why i
was taking notes but i see your face and
i i understand
but i was taking notes about that about
what she said the first thing that i got
to say about that right off the bat
right there before we keep on going with
the video is the first thing is
the image that your parents are what
your parents are it's not what it is
okay a thing about your parents is
hiding a lot of [ __ ] from you
make it look like everything is all
right your parents goal is to
often times not always sometimes you
know there's some parents that fail
but oftentimes your parents uh your
parents goal of what they try to set it
up
is they try to make everything
look good or make the kids not suffer so
the image that you have of your parents
is often not what you think
it's not really what's going on they
hide it parents hide
oftentimes they they hide a lot of [ __ ]
from you and i
actually there's a saying that i say
often is
you become an adult you know when
someone comes up to me and be like yo
when do you become an adult it's not an
age thing
you become an adult when there's a part
of your childhood that dies
when you realize that your parents are
not that the greatest or not that great
or not that's your dad is not the
strongest he's not the greatest
and he has the flaw he has flaws and
that your mom has his flaws
once you realize that you don't
necessarily become an adult
but your childhood dream dies
there you know i mean and there's some
people it's sooner than before
some people is younger than before
that's one two
the thing about having kids and really
wanted to have kids no matter what
whether their male is there or not
matter whether
it's very selfish you have to ask
yourself whenever you're
whenever you you want to have kids
people always ask themselves do
i want to have kids i want to ask kids
or the question that they ask themselves
is
do i want to have kids and to me it's
just the wrong question
the question you should ask yourself is
not whether you should want kids or not
whether you want to be a parent or not
that's the question because having kids
is one thing
being a parent is some other [ __ ] like
what's the difference there
you having a kid is just you having a
kid just
the way that it sounds is you having a
baby it's a thing that happens
being a parent is a role having a kid
is a possession and just by saying
i want a kid it's really just and just
making the difference between having a
kid
and want being wanting to be a parent
just knowing the difference between that
and the intention behind those two
things
makes you more conscious of those two
things of those two positions i want a
baby i want a baby when you want a baby
you really just think about
all the positive things about this and
sometimes i
i see people that really want kids that
are like very
i'm tired this and that it's so hard no
because you wanted a kid you didn't want
to be
a parent but when you want to be a
parent
and you want and you you take that in
consideration
and you you really think about the
intention
beyond the difference of being a parent
and wanting a baby
there's choices that you know that
there's some choices and hard choices
you're going to make being a parent is
not about you no more
being a bait how wanting a baby and
posting pictures and [ __ ] like that
and having that kid that's that's about
that's about that's about you being a
parent
ain't got nothing to do with you that's
the reason why i don't know
but you don't hear that how selfish that
sounds uh if i don't find somebody and
it's not to
i don't if i don't have exactly what my
parents had then i'm not going to set
them
but you're going to make your child
settle for a situation that is less than
ideal
he's going to have a whole friendly that
child's gonna have a family
he's not gonna have a father
he can still have a father like if i
meet someone
that would agree to have a baby but we
don't have to get married or live
together
but he can still be a good father that
can happen
like a like um um
so how do you bruh
oh the thing is i've seen
that way of thinking like you put the
real
that's the thing that's not even okay
this subject is no longer about having
kids and everything and stuff it's about
arguing with people and proving a point
okay when you argue with someone you're
not even if you have
all the facts all the statistics
all the logic you might not even
most of the time you're not going to
change the person's perspective
because they are so ingrained in their
way of thinking
that it doesn't matter you can bring all
the analogy
the logical analogies that you want it's
not
gonna change their point of view you
know why because they really want a baby
and there's nothing that's going to go
against that you understand what i'm
saying
yeah if you replace baby and you take
and you put i really want a dog
yeah but you live in a one and a half
sounds the same
you don't have the space to raise a
husky
but i really want a dog you don't have
the backyard to put him in
i really want a dog you don't have the
money to feed him
i really want a dog if i can find
someone else
like maybe one day i'll have a job that
will be able to change
and someone's gonna be able to yeah but
your landlord doesn't allow dogs i
really want a dog
like they don't hear you because they're
them wanting really to have a dog is
more important than any logic that
you're going to instill in them
now replace dog with baby yeah
it doesn't matter that's what makes it
very selfish
i always say to my people that love dogs
if you really really
really love dogs all that much and you
would really love animals
all that much you wouldn't have any
but they really want dogs so they have
them
yeah and they get them neutered and they
they encourage
all those the people that are selling
them and that are breeding them in the
wrong way
that's what you're doing but if you
really wanted that you wouldn't have
that but no
she really wants a baby so she's gonna
have her baby whether you want it or not
you know what really struck me is like
really odd during the whole conversation
it was like
she's talked about how she wanted to
have her parents love
she said i don't have a love and respect
like my parents i don't want anything
else
i'm never going to settle but i'm going
to look at my kids and bring them into
an environment that's less than ideal
and force them to settle
yep what kind of entitlement and
selfishness do you have to have
if you're going to be a parent this is
what it is i'm not saying
you should settle to have kids i'm
saying if you're going to have kids
settle because you owe it to them to do
everything in your power to bring them
into an environment that's best for them
when you are a parent it's no longer
about you and what your sense of
happiness is
theirs comes first and if you don't
understand that order
i would argue that you're a negligent
parent if you think that your happiness
and what you want and like
i want a man who has his ambition or
who's i'm passionate about
and you won't find a father for that
child because you didn't have that
how is it fair to them you talked about
oh i'm gonna find a man and maybe he's
gonna give me the sperm
that sound like a father figure too what
if he has another family and he doesn't
want anything to do with the kid anymore
imagine how much that's gonna [ __ ] that
child up but people don't
care it doesn't matter because i'm not
going to settle
well don't be a parent don't be no but
she's not but she's not
she she's not she doesn't want to be a
parent she wants to have a baby
and that's why in my head there's really
a difference between wanting to be a
parent
and wanting to have a baby i don't have
a baby right now
at 38 i don't have a baby because i
didn't want to be a parent
there's a certain sadness and people
like this
bringing these kids into this world not
knowing how it's going to affect them to
not have one of their father figures
we'll talk to kids from single-parent
households and how much it [ __ ] them
up to not have a men
or to not have like a male or feminine
like a motherly figure in their life
and how much they long for that you know
and if they don't get it from your
family they'll go to some place and you
better hope it's a good place
you better hope the person's adequate
you better hope the person doesn't take
advantage of them you better hope it's
not a criminal organization
you better hope it's not the wrong
people but they will seek it out
they will seek it out there's a reason
why a lot of the people
who are in prison right now come from a
lot of these households
you know so when i talk about this it
sets me off
because i get messages every day from
people who are like man i didn't have a
dad
and like a blind preacher you know i
don't think we're good
mentor figures or things like that to
people no but we have those messages
every day
every day and i'm like you're going to
bring kids into scenarios where they may
not even have that
by choice who told you
you could be that entitled but she won't
but that's the privilege
abba let me tell you something privilege
is not just white privilege
is not just white i must say that again
privilege is not just white and you know
whenever we have a group of friends
right i've i've always been
straightforward
and told you and told the rest of our
[ __ ] that i was super privileged
when you you you have to know the
privilege that you have
both my parents are together both my
parents are educated
both my parents are i have jobs both my
parents my mom was savvy with her money
and she was able to do that
so growing up it was not a burden it was
never a burden
money was not a burden i didn't have to
provide for my mom but i know a lot of
mother
that did i know a lot of mother because
i had to
put that weight as a as a kid they had
to pull that weight
that's privilege right that's the
privilege that i have
i'd be selfish and be and i'd be
self-centered to be like no no no no no
i'm good i'm just
i'm aware of that right but people are
not aware of that and they're going to
be like no no it's going to be like that
it's just fine it's just easy no you've
never been through that
you've never been maybe i've been
privileged but a lot of my friends were
were living in the projects and living
and i was chilling with them so i i was
not living it but i saw
it i saw how it was right i
saw how it was in the burden there was
that that to be a single mother and
raising of
five kids or two kids or even one kid
bro every single mom who was watching
that live when i
this girl is [ __ ] i wish i had a
partner
because this [ __ ] is so hard by myself
and you know what all this talk i like
my friends and families are going to
support me
you know that girl's old very fast for
them they get busy
and you get tired of having to scramble
and pray that someone makes the time to
help
so a lot of people live very
disillusioned about this whole like oh
well my whole village is going to come
around this time
you'd be lucky you'd be one of the
fortunate ones so
it's just one of those things where i
just don't believe it i don't buy into
it for the most part
you know it speaks again to the whole
idea that i i'm really starting to buy
into that
more and more societies basically saying
like we don't need men
cause you're not gonna hear guys talk
goofy [ __ ] like this you're not gonna
hear guys talk about like if i can't
have i'm going to raise a kid by myself
you
never hear that i've never heard that my
whole life all of a sudden i do alive
and like 30 of these ladies come out of
nowhere
yeah i really need to have a show people
really think that we bugging when we
talking about that
men are disposable i'm just gonna take
the sperm
and raise a kid yeah okay so i'm just
okay you you you mad when you're just
you're just a body you're just a whole
you're just this but you're gonna you
hear yourself talk and you're like
you're just gonna take you're just gonna
take the sperm so i'm just a donor
oh okay and it's not even that is that's
normal because if a man goes
i'm just gonna that girl she's just a
whole real quick we're going to go to
them but if a woman says
i'm just going to look for some sperm
and whatever nobody bats tonight nobody
nobody says disposable disposable we're
expected to give up her lives to work
and break her backs and do all this
other stuff and then also be told at the
same time that we're not necessary for
most things
it's just like it's crazy to me how
flippantly people talk about raising
kids without fathers in life
um so like i said this is not addressed
to people who are single mothers by no
choice of their own
this is just the people who are actively
choosing this lifestyle thinking it's
hilarious
because at that time he doesn't have to
commit to me so he can do whatever he
wants
and he's going to be happy and i'm not
going to give him a hard time
you you grow up maybe you don't
understand it but for kids who grew up
in single-parent households
it is not an easy life
when i hear you saying like no you don't
no you don't you don't no you don't
when she said i know like that she was
not knowing it she was
pushing it aside i hope she watches this
video and realize how goofy she sounds
and how dangerous her ideas
you know i hope but you know who knows
who knows right
so anyways i just wanted to kind of
share this clip but listen you guys let
me know what you guys think in the
comments below if you guys enjoyed
today's video
like comment all right help us out the
algorithm is always kind to us youtube
has been
flagging us on some bull so if you guys
are enjoying today's content you know
what to do
all right all right well listen uh
someone said even if it's abusive why do
people always say that
well i don't understand who's talking
about somebody putting your physical
health in danger you know what i'm
saying
like i'm talking about i would stay in a
relationship that's not ideal
yeah what if he beats you what that's a
crime
you're asking me yeah what if he [ __ ]
rejects crack in his arm every night
did i mean like wait why would you bring
that example that's why i don't
understand like
you should stay in a relationship even
it's difficult imagine if i use that for
business okay
imagine i use that hey man you and your
partner you guys you guys are budding
business i should make it work no matter
what
yeah but what if my partner is like
snorting heroin every night and just
like [ __ ] hookers at the job
[ __ ] what i just thought like maybe
i'll disagree on business direction
nah man this [ __ ] he's like engaging in
human trafficking
should i stay with him it's a crime
if your partner beats you that's
criminal
you know what i'm saying like why is it
that when i have the discussion people
always bring up extremes
yeah but what if your partner like you
know what i'm saying they just pin you
down on the table and even if you don't
want you they just take you
what that's sent that [ __ ] to jail
who told you that it's a good idea to
stay with a [ __ ] criminal
you know me
it's like like like i don't know man i
just find sometimes when i have these
conversations
yeah but like what if that man stabbed
you on a saturday like should you stay
with him
yeah he killed my he killed my mom
should i stay with this [ __ ] because i
want to make it worse
i got no grandma but like i still got a
baby daddy
y'all killing me bro
i hate i hate it i hate it when people
bring up these extreme scenarios
hey guys you shouldn't be super
superficial man like
you should you should try to stay with
the girl even if she's not the best
looking
yeah but what if the [ __ ] ain't got no
legs [ __ ] what
why are you bringing that up i just said
i just said you don't have to be
superficial
yeah yeah but what if she lost her legs
in an accident and then she lost both of
her arms
and now she's just a torso just rolling
around should i still love her
[ __ ]
y'all be killing me bro y'all be making
me laugh with some of these examples
y'all killing me man hey listen if the
guy's not making that much money you
know what it's fine
yeah what if this [ __ ] is a hundred
thousand dollars in debt he wants me to
pay his car loans
why not
[Music]
oh